[Music]
here we will tell you all about the
origins the biology and the Seven life
cycle stages of a demogorgon so let's
get to it
let's start with the origins these
monsters called demogorgons are
carnivorous monsters from the upside
down dimension of stranger things all
demogorgons encountered so far are
considered to be followers of either
Wagner or the Mind flayer and are a part
of The Upside Down's hive mind they are
bloodthirsty vicious creatures and have
limited intelligence they have inhabited
the upside down Dimension way before
Wagner took control of the hive mine
they are probably one of the apex
predators of that place and are a vital
part of the desolate ecosystem operating
as top hunters for prey that have yet
been seen
so let's take a look at their biology
and Anatomy the demogorgon is a bipedal
creature with two long four Limbs and
two slim but powerful hind legs it has a
humanoid body structure but that's about
all it has that is similar between it
and a human its skin is bulletproof and
has a very dense skeletal and muscular
structure underneath its tough height
the hands have very long fingers that
end with sharp claws capable of cutting
through steel the legs are digital great
and have two toes with an extra one high
on the heel but each one of them
possessing a long Claw at the end the
head is the most intriguing part as it
opens up like a pedal with 5 detachable
lips having hundreds of balls and teeth
lying in rows along the mouth it is
carnivorous inhabit and possesses a
digestive system capable of taking in
meat and flesh from both the upside down
life forms and the real world creatures
as well but in its early stages it can
ingest and process a wide variety of
food substances including candy and
anything biological in nature including
plants when it grows it becomes an
obligate carnivore in that it only
prefers to kill and eat other animals
and also humans it possesses a stomach
with a very strong acid and also a very
slimy saliva one very unique trait in
that these creatures possess no eyes and
are thought to rely on other senses like
sound like a graboid from Tremors or the
death angels from that movie and other
unknown sensors like Xenomorphs okay so
now let's get into the life cycle of
these monsters from the upside down a
demogorgon's life cycle appears to
include six or seven different phases
and is compared in some aspects to those
of Earth amphibian species the cycle
begins with the jumping of eggs or lava
into a hose by a tentacle within the
upside down in that those are the only
examples of demogorgan reproduction
documented the eggs are probably the
first stage and are not seen But
theorized to exist as lava are always a
second stage in any animal life cycle
after emerging from a particular egg the
second stage lavas the larval
demogorgons are similar in shape and
size to garden slugs however they are
colored and definitely shaped level
demogorgons are dark green in color with
Vivid yellow markings and spots they are
slimy and move about in a slow manner
they hatch from eggs that are inserted
in a human or an animal's body which
means that they are likely similar to
the embryo of the Xenomorphs that are
impregnated in a human host by face
hugger similar in a way but they need to
come out in order to further their own
life cycle the third stage is called the
poliwap a Laval demogorgon with malt
into the next stage of its life cycle
after an undetermined period of time and
was frequently referred to as a
pollywalk during that time or into its
similarity to the larval stage of frogs
pollywogs are small enough to fit in the
palm of your hand and their transparent
skin is yellow green in Hue they have
two volumes with claw like hands a mouth
and a lizard-like tail they are
extremely sensitive to heat even direct
exposure to light and sun or table lamp
causes them great Agony they appear to
be opportunistic feeders at this time
eating anything in their pot so we come
to the fourth stage which is a
quadrupedal poly walk the fourth stage
of the cycle unlike the previous ones is
not entered by a creature's molting it
is grown gradually this stage is instead
indicated by the poliwog's skin turning
a dark green Hue and an increase in body
bulk the Bodywork will then develop hind
legs and become quadrupedal the
creature's mouth begins to acquire a
little sharp teeth in its mouth in this
form it can move more freely and hop
around in a limited manner but still
leaving slime wherever they go
so the fifth stage this is called the
categorgan because it somehow resembles
a house cat in size habit and movement
so when the poliwap has consumed enough
food in molds and grows into the size of
a typical House Gap it is during the
stage that the juvenile demogorgon
develops the species signature pittle
mouth furthermore the juvenile develops
carnivorous habits and its skins darkens
and becomes heat resistant allowing it
to walk in the sunshine without damage
the sixth stage the Adolescent
demogorgon then matures into a
considerably larger version of their
former form after molting into the
second last stage of their life cycle
which Dustin refers to as a demo dog the
demador now nearly the size of a huge
dog like a Saint Bernard is strong
enough to take on a grown human they are
skilled and constructing tunnels and
climbing steep Cliffs while a demo dog
is not really immune to gunfire its skin
is thick enough to withstand many shots
their demo dog do have a lot of
similarities with the demogorgon such as
mouth and skin but are more quadripetal
than their bipedal counterpart then
finally we have the mature demogorgon
this creature emerges as an adult after
molting for the last time adult
demogorgons are by peel and grow to be
around 6 to 10 feet tall depending on
the specimen they have Incredible
strength and can easily knock a door off
its hinges and pin down an adult person
their sense of smell is extremely acute
capable of detecting a trace of blood
from the upside down their skin has
become tough enough to resist gunshots
and many strikes from a spiky instrument
it also now has the ability to travel to
and from the earth and the upside down
by using riffs that it is able to create
like portals thereby becoming a monster
that is fearsome and almost unkillable
so that's it that's all about the
demogorg in its life cycle Origins and
biology do hit the like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash the Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel